♪♪
どっこいしょ
ぐきっ
あああああああああああああああああああああああああああああ
こんにちははじめしゃちょーです。
東京に新居を借りてかなり日が経ちましたが、
この部屋で使っているのは、ただ一つ。
もったいない。
非常にもったいなくて、僕なんでこの東京に家借りたかと冷静に考えてみたんですけど
目が疲れてるな。
もう目が疲れてるよ
静岡に帰る時間がもったいなくて時間がないから、こっちの東京の部屋で編集とか泊まったりできればいいなって。
編集ですよ！
そう編集するために、僕はこの部屋を借りたはずなのに、
ほぼ編集をしない。
ノートパソコンで隅っこに座っていつもやってるんで、
ノートパソコンも、結構ガタが来てて。
めっちゃ止まるんですよ、最近。
もうほんとフリーズしかしない。
いつも使ってるノートパソコンもう限界なので、
今回新しくデスクトップのパソコンを買いました。
それを東京に置こうと思って、
全部買って！
すぐ作ろうと思ったんですけど、
箱から出して３分で飽きちゃって、
この状態が9月からずっと続いております。
やっべっぞ！
さすがのおいらでもやばいと感じてしまったので、
今日は何としてでも東京に
編集部屋を作ります。
この部屋をですよ。
この部屋を今日僕は頑張って編集部屋にして、
僕は寝ます。
ただいま深夜2時14分。
せっしゃは明日、
8時ぐらいから用事があるでござる、
やるしかねえ！
もうなんとしてでもやるからね！
今日は編集部屋を作るまで寝れまてん。
よーしでは頑張って作っていきましょう！
もうやるって決めたから俺。
まずはPCデスクを作ります。
え、え、え、え、え、え、え、え、え、！！！１
うわーかた。
もうだめだ人力じゃだめだ。
さすが、滑らねえぜ、
アバンティーズ。
OK～
もうこれであと上に載せるだけっしょ。
ひとまず、どこに置くかの場所だけ決めよう。
これでたぶん机を載せるだけで完成です。
よし載せるぞ。
机完成です
1時間半かかったぞー
こんなに大変？
まずは、キーボードパットをおいて、
次にマウスパットを置く。
しゃあまず机の上はこんな感じでございます。
なんか中にもいろいろおけそうですな。
机じたい、すごくいい感じだと思います。
これあれだな。
机ができた瞬間、テンション上がるな。
こいうたちなの？
ちょいちょいちょいこんなに前なの？前？
待って「ばき」つったー
まてまて「ばき」はやばい、。
パソコンはね、バキっつったらマジで終わる。
ゴミ箱です。
なんかおいらの編集細かいの多いじゃないですか。。
カットも出し、テキストとかも結構入れるんですけど、
このパソコンだとスムーズにできるので、本当助かってます。
さあ行くぞ、Mac Pro
マスス！キーボード！
ということで、ほぼ完成に近づいたパソコンまわり
もう一つ足りないものがあります。
それは何か。
いー、いーいーいー。
完成です。
というわけでこのゲーミングチェアー。静岡にあるイスと同じ会社の椅子でございます。
基本的には静岡においてあるやつと同じ形で、作りました。
やっとできました～。
もっと東京に部屋を借りたときにすぐ作ればよかったんですけれども、
ようやく態勢が整えることができました。
僕赤黒が好きなんですけれども、
ちょっと東京の机周りは、静岡とは異なってね、
青と黒で埋め尽くして、パソコン周り作ってみました。いかがでしょうか。
もうマジでね、ノートパソコンがいかれすぎて、マジ使い物にならなくて
東京で編集するときは、苦しみながらやっていたんですけど。
これで、快適に編集できればと思っております。
あー